On August 21, 2017
the shadow of the Moon will pass
from the west coast
to the east coast of the U.S.
Our blue sky will turn black as night
and fill with stars,
and there will be a hole in the sky
where the Sun used to be,
surrounded by the fiery
ring of the Sun's corona,
a total eclipse of the Sun.
This will truly be a historic event.
Accounts of solar eclipses
date way back on the written record.
The early Mesopotamians wrote
that the Sun was put to shame
during the solar eclipse
of the 14th century B.C.E.
and it may have started
the Sun worship of the Egyptian
pharaoh Akhenaten.
Ancient Chinese astrologers
paid with their lives
if they failed to predict
the solar eclipse
and portend the fate of their emperors
whose symbol was the Sun.
The earliest date of a specific
event in human history,
a battle between the armies
of Lydia and Media,
occurred on May 28, 535 B.C.E.
when a solar eclipse caused the soldiers
to lay down their arms
and declare a truce.
So how does it happen?
During a total solar eclipse,
the Moon moves
between the Earth and the Sun.
When this happens, the disc of the Moon
appears to perfectly cover
the disc of the Sun
even though the Sun is much
larger than the Moon.
But how is this possible?
The Sun is 400 times bigger than the Moon,
but by sheer coincidence,
the Moon is 390 times closer to Earth.
Size and distance cancel each other out
so that the Moon and Sun appear
to be almost the exactly same size.
Every time the Moon orbits the Earth,
once every 27.3 days,
it has to pass
between the Earth and the Sun,
a stage called the new moon phase.
And every time it passes,
the New Moon has a chance
to block out the Sun.
Most of the time,
the Moon passes a little above
or a little below the Sun,
but if they align perfectly,
the shadow of the Moon
will make a narrow path across Earth
and those in the shadows
will see a total solar eclipse.
Just like on night side of the Earth,
the sky during a total eclipse is black
and filled with stars.
But while the moon perfectly covers
the surface of the Sun,
it doesn't block
out the Sun's outer atmosphere,
its corona, which appears as a fiery ring
around the dark disc of the moon.
Solar eclipses occur several times a year,
but most often they are partial eclipses
where the Moon doesn't quite
line up with the Sun.
And, when the Moon and Sun
are perfectly aligned,
the Moon is usually too far
from Earth in its orbit
to completely cover the Sun,
creating an annular eclipse.
During an annular or partial eclipse,
the sky remains bright.
Even on those rare occasions
of a total eclipse,
the Moon's shadow is most likely to fall
on the 70% of Earth
that is covered by water,
and few people, if any, will see it.
The eclipse of 2017 will be
remarkable on a larger scale
because the Moon is slowly
moving away from Earth.
If a furry ancestor of ours
had bothered to look up
during a solar eclipse
a hundred million years ago,
it wouldn't have seen
the fiery corona of the Sun.
It would have just been dark.
Eventually, the Moon will have
moved too far from Earth
to completely cover the disc of the Sun.
It is only during our little wink
of Earth's history
that the Moon is at just
the right distance
to cause a total solar eclipse
yet not block the Sun's corona.
So on August 21, 2017,
when the Moon exactly
lines up with the Sun
and the Moon is close enough to the Earth,
its shadow will cross the U.S.
and, if you happen to be
in its narrow path,
you will witness one of the most
awe-inspiring sights in the universe.
But, as incredible as this event will be,
total eclipses
are one of the most dangerous as well.
Only specially tinted filters,
specifically designed to observe the Sun,
should be used.
The eclipse might put the Sun to shame,
but even a shamed Sun
can seriously damage your eyes.